ah é então eu vim falar de um tema que é
bastante sério e bastante é necessário
eu acho na sociedade que a gente tá
vivendo que é o tema de gênero falar
sobre mulher falar sobre discriminação
sobre preconceito e falar de mídia
também né como que a mídia tem abordado
é a questão da mulher como é que a mídia
é reproduz estereótipos diariamente eu
venho estudado isso já faz um tempo né
foi tema enfim né de tcc e minha
dissertação de mestrado e é uma coisa
que eu pretendo fazer no doutorado
também dessa representação midiática que
a gente tem da mulher hoje né eu tenho
certeza que todo mundo ouvir diariamente
não são mulheres mas vocês homens também
sobre a tá dirigindo mal né então com
certeza é uma mulher ou então aí ela
apanhou talvez ela gosta de apanhar
quem gosta de apanhar ela foi estuprada
bom olha o horário que ela tava na rua
né 10 horas da noite é o horário de uma
mulher andar sozinha na rua ou então
talvez a roupa que ela está vestindo
então existe também o excesso de
culpabilização da mulher e da figura da
mulher então é sempre foi ela ela que
produziu e quando você é mãe você ouve
diariamente outras coisas também do tipo
nossa mas você já é mãe não mas você só
é mãe você só cuida dessa criança e
quando que vem o próxima então mas você
gosta de ter bebê
quem é e a sua vida profissional como é
que fica então as pessoas diariamente
falam né sobre e as mulheres são o tempo
todo interrogados e questionadas por
essa figura de ser mulher e aí trazendo
né todos esses dados e e essa essa
reprodução que a gente tem hoje na
sociedade de alguns discursos a gente
tem dados né de fatos que acontecem com
mulheres
é isso acabei que não tá aparecendo aqui
e eu
g1
bom então gente aliado a esses
estereótipos e a esse senso comum que a
gente tem sobre o que essa mulher na
sociedade a gente tem dados que uma
mulher é vítima de estupro a cada 9
minutos no brasil a gente tem que três
mulheres vítimas de feminicídio a cada
um dia no país a gente tem uma mulher
que registra agressão sobre a lei maria
da penha a cada dois minutos isso
levando em consideração as mulheres que
conseguem ter coragem de denunciar sobre
quem bate nela sobre quem a ser dia
sobre quem ali exercendo um certo poder
sobre ela também né então a gente tem
dados alarmantes no brasil o brasil é um
país que violenta muito a mulher tanto
violência física como violência
psicológica a gente traz a capital do
espírito santo a gente tem é um estado
que mata muita mulher que machuca muita
mulher e e as coisas vão acontecendo né
e a gente tem dados e aí a
a mídia né também que tem um papel nessa
reprodução também e aí eu trouxe alguns
exemplos para vocês de algumas
reportagens né que tem algum tipo de
repercussão na mídia né em grandes
aparecem grandes grandes emissoras que
fazem que publicam sobre a mulher e a
gente tem um panorama né desses estudos
que vêm sendo realizados por vários
pesquisadores de várias partes do país e
como que a mulher colocada na mídia e o
panorama é bastante assustador quando
você fala dos meios de comunicação
trazendo a mulher na publicidade a gente
tem que sempre uma hipersexualização da
figura daquela mulher é uma mulher que
tem que ser perfeita uma mulher que é
responsabilidade responsabilizada
diariamente por tudo inclusive né esse
estudo que com as mulheres que trabalham
e são responsáveis pelo sobrepeso do seu
filho pokémon só está trabalhando ela
não tá cuidando direito de casa né e a
mulher ela tem que dar conta de tudo
também é a gente teve na última copa as
atletas um show
as reportagens e publicações
extremamente machistas relacionadas às
mulheres eram sempre as atletas tiveram
listas não são as atletas mas também das
torcedoras as torcedoras mais bonitas da
copa as torcedoras mais sensuais as
melhores torcedoras as atletas mais
olimpicamente atrativas então ficam
fazendo rank de tudo né quando a gente
pensa nessa figura da mulher aí a gente
traz aqui uma reportagem do globo uma
mulher com opinião porque afinal de
contas né mulher não tem opinião
e é uma reportagem do você amanhã a
gente tem as novas regras sendo impostas
né eu tipo você vocês homens se cuidem
porque o futuro de vocês amanhã é ser
mulher portanto é ser alguém que tá ali
nessa figura mais sub julgada também é
essa brincadeira que que se tem dessa
divisão também sexual de que brincadeira
de menino brincadeira de menina também
sendo reproduzida na nossas mídias e aí
eu sou né da fato latas que além de
atletas hoje também são bonitas como se
tivessem essa separação é vez em dois
ramos ganhou a medalha de bronze que é a
esposa de não é ela ela é alguém que
pertence a um homem também né então é
esposa de namorada de que ganhou uma
medalha de bronze então aí a gente tem
esse a gente pensar na mídia né são
alguns exemplos que eu trouxe a gente
pensa no nosso aparelho aparato
midiático
e a gente tem alguns problemas quando a
gente pensa nessa mídia no brasil e a
medida se desenvolve evolui no sentido
de que a gente tem uma mudança dos meios
de comunicação com o surgimento da
internet a gente tem um desaparecimento
de alguns jornais impressos de televisão
de revista e a gente tem a criação de
outros meios de comunicação muito com a
internet então existe uma certa
reinvenção quando a gente fala nesse
meio de comunicação também mas a essa
representação da mulher ela continua
sendo mesmo com essa evolução a continua
sendo feita da mesma maneira né claro
que a gente fala que de forma mais geral
mas ainda reproduzida sempre é com essa
ideia mais é preconceituosa e essa
reprodução dos estereótipos e aí um tema
aqui assim trabalhar sem forma bem bem
simples do que a gente tem no brasil
hoje uma concentração dos meios de
comunicação o brasil é um dos países
campeão assim né
e lá no ranking de países que não têm
pluralidade nos meios de comunicação a
gente tem a concentração dos meios de
comunicação nas mãos de poucas pessoas
são poucas famílias que hoje detém o
poder dos meios de comunicação no brasil
e a gente tem quase todos os mesmos
recordes sobre determinados assuntos
iguais a gente vê determinado assunto
sendo publicado em x emissora na
emissora y ela vai ser publicada quase
igual com uma outra diferença mas
intendente o abordagem ela continua
sendo feita quase de forma igualitária
né e aí um outro problema também assim
para a gente pensar é que oitenta por
cento dessas empresas de mídia elas têm
sedes entre sul e sudeste do país eu
venho do norte não não tô falando aqui
com o lugar de fala e etc mas a gente
tem a reprodução de estereótipos não só
da mulher mas por exemplo do baiano da
figura do nordestino que é sempre uma
figura muito engraçada
esse é o baiano que é tido como uma
pessoa que é preguiçosa portanto a gente
tem essa reprodução dessas esses
estereótipos e são difíceis de ser
quebrado já que a gente tem essa
concentração de mídia muito nesse eixo
rio-são paulo né isso também mas mais
principalmente aqui então é pensando por
exemplo a questão de religião quando se
trabalha sempre a questão por exemplo a
umbanda o candomblé são religiões tidas
como a macumba então portanto não serve
então tem alguns preconceitos também
estabelecidos por conta dessa
concentração midiática também que a
gente tem né é e aí então como é que
ficariam como é que ficam esses
estereótipos né que esse recorte de
gênero nessa representação jornalística
que a gente tem é uma pergunta que para
a gente pensar um pouco e aí entendendo
essa representação jornalística né bom a
gente tá aqui pensando em meios de
comunicação e aí puxando para o
jornalismo que a minha ara tem um
notícias sobre de
o crescimento eu vou fazer um recorte do
real é claro se eu vou noticiar que eu
vou escrever agora o que tá acontecendo
aqui eu posso selecionar o que que eu
vou noticiar eu vou falar somente disso
ou daquilo então eu tô fazendo o tempo
todo escolhas para falar sobre
determinado acontecimento então quanto
eu vou falar também sobre a mulher no
jornalismo eu seleciona a seleção não
essa foto eu seleciona essa fonte eu
seleciono determinado o título então a
gente que é que tá aí trabalhando tem
muita gente do mercado dos meios de
comunicação a gente tem essa
oportunidade também de dar uma outra
abordagem então era para a gente
perceber criticamente essa mídia e essas
possibilidades que a gente tem também de
fazer outra abordagem né quando a gente
fala não só de gênero mas quando a gente
discute a questão de raça também né aqui
no brasil fazendo menção ao dia da
consciência negra que foi ontem né e aí
a gente tem uma paródia ideológico no
brasil que é muito forte que a gente tem
um aparato que é racista sexista
o que é uma fóbico a gente tem também
falando da população lgbt key mais a
gente tem o brasil é um país que
assassina muitos gays né muitas mulheres
estão assim é as minorias no brasil hoje
elas são muito mal tratadas né e aí a
gente tem sofre um duplo uma dupla
agressão é quando você sofre com isso na
sociedade e como que a mídia também
notícia você pro sociedade então é um
duplo ataque a essas pessoas né e
falando não diminui as enquanto pessoas
mas as minorias sociais onde as mulheres
também estão incluídas e outra coisa
também que a gente não pode deixar de
falar e a questão de classe também né
então se a gente pensa todos todas nós
mulheres a gente sofre hoje com algum
tipo de preconceito seja no trabalho
seja na academia seja na faculdade em
qualquer lugar mas se você pega uma
mulher negra pobre de periferia ela
sofre preconceito ainda maior então
assim a gente tem uma sub-representação
a mão da mulher na mídia que é como a
gente utiliza e uma sub-representação
dessa mulher se a gente pega essa mulher
de classes mais baixas também pra gente
não pode tirar essa discussão de gênero
desse contexto de raça e classe então
são temas que a gente tem que trabalhar
sempre em conjunto é então né enfim com
base em estudos e etc não só estudos
meus mas estudos de outras pessoas que
têm feito isso né nesses estudos de
mídia como que essa mulher ela como é
que essa imprensa ela fala sobre a
mulher né como essa mulher no geral é
noticiado na imprensa hoje pensando com
todos desenvolvimento que a gente tem é
o século que a gente vive o ano que a
gente vive e etc né então a gente sempre
gira em torno de temas tradicionais é
sempre a mulher que é mãe é sempre a
mulher que a esposa e às vezes como que
coloca a mulher na figura de uma
profissional bem-sucedida a gente também
tem uma mulher que tem que ser
multifuncional portão só tem que dar
conta de
a forma muito perfeita do seu trabalho
da sua casa do seu marido você tem que
ser perfeita e estar perfeita o tempo
todo então a cobrança também sobre essa
mulher é então quando a gente pensa né a
violência contra a mulher e pensando
violência não só essa questão da
violência fiz mas violência psicológica
fio violência ou assédio sexual de
quantas vezes você não passa na rua e
mexem com você e eu não sei se vocês
ficaram sabendo mas tem um documentário
que foi produzido chega de que o fio em
que as mulheres passavam e os homens
mexiam e aí ela te perguntar você você
sabe que isso é assédio ele falava
imagina isso não é assédio isso é uma
forma de eu dizer para ela que ela está
bonita que ela tá bonita então as
pessoas nem entendem as formas de
violência que elas praticam em cima das
mulheres né então a gente as pesquisas
elas pontão algumas tendências uma delas
é essa reprodução de estereótipos a
gente tem essa mídia
é essa mulher que tem que ser mãe essa
mulher que tem que ser esposa não
significa se ela não quer casar ela tem
que casar porque ela tem que ser não
significa que ela não quer ter um filho
ela tem que ter que a mulher tem que ser
o que você não entende socialmente que
ela tem que ser então essa figura que
pede muito também essa sonegação de
informação de serviços você fala sobre a
violência e não tem lá no final olha
você pode recorrer se você sofrer esse
tipo de violência você pode recorrer
você pode ligar para esse número então
nessas pesquisas feitas não há essa
divulgação dessa informação dentro né
dessas dessas notícias enfim e essa
excesso de contabilização das mulheres
também foi foi estuprada e teve um caso
que aquele estupro coletivo no rio de
janeiro ficou muito conhecido né no
mundo inteiro e que todas as análises
das pessoas da mídia de como que a mídia
cobriu e de pessoas que estudaram sobre
isso é a culpa urbanização dela porque é
veio um discurso de que ela estava as 10
horas da noite
hoje a noite é uma hora não importa na
rua porque ela tinha um sido um filho
aos 13 anos porque ela era usuária de
drogas porque em coisas para justificar
o estupro que ela teve porque sei lá não
foram tantos homens assim que né
chegaram de fato a estuprá-la enfim
então acesso da sua pedida o
culpabilização dessa mulher também e a
gente tem alguma presença abundante das
mulheres na mídia faltou foto coloca uma
mulher existe até uma teórica que fala
de uma bunda alização midiática é bunda
bunda bunda bunda da mulher é sempre a
bunda o corpo seios essas partes da
mulher é colocadas ali sempre à mostra
como se isso né vendesse atraísse
leitores né então é um outro tema também
para um debate mais não e esse padrão de
beleza que se cobra da mulher e existe
também um padrão de beleza que é
colocado pela mulher a mulher tem que
ser parecer branca tem que ser magra tem
que ser loira tem que atender a um
padrão de beleza que a gente fala um
padrão e g
oi e aí falando no brasil que é um
parece pensando na nossa colonização do
da mistura de povos que a gente tem que
a gente é caboclo que índio então se
pede que essa mulher seja desse jeito né
então a gente também tem aí a
trabalhando até um certo sofrimento
também da mulher que não atende a esses
padrões é que que se pede e essa questão
dessas mulheres musas é sempre a musa do
carnaval a musa da copa do mundo a musa
de qualquer lugar coloca uma mulher como
se ela fosse musa como se ela não
pudesse usar um espaço sem ser musa de
alguma coisa né e mulheres jovens também
né como se fosse crime envelhecer a
questão dessas mulheres sempre muito
brancas magras loiras esse cabelo liso
também e essa visão também que a gente
tem fora do país a gente a mulher quando
fala que é bom eu sou do brasil a então
você é fácil a mulher do brasil é tido
como uma mulher fácil fora daí então
você já fala tem até
um depoimento das mulheres que falam eu
me sinto mal em sair do brasil e falar
que eu sou do brasil que as pessoas
acham que eu tô ali disposta disposta a
tá lidando alguma coisa mais então se
tem essa visão né sobre a mulher aqui no
brasil também é que são sexualmente
receptivas né que a raquel morena usa
muito então né a gente não pode falar
dessa violência de gênero isolado desse
contexto também é a gente precisa falar
essa opção de gênero a gente precisa
trabalhar pensar sobre isso diariamente
né trabalhar com isso todos os dias quem
é que profissionais de comunicação ao
pensar um cartaz publicitário pensar
qual que é a mulher como é que você vai
retratar aquela mulher ali você a pensar
em uma capa de jornal a foto que você
vai usar como que você vai estar
retratando a mulher ela só vai estar ali
sendo um objeto do seu trabalho como né
amiga já vem trabalhando também há muito
tempo e aí eu trouxe do estações né pra
gente finalizar e a mulher lá é
duplamente tem um seus direitos violados
e o quando ele é agredida pela sociedade
seja consegue sexual assédio moral
falando também na questão do trabalho
tal e quando a mídia também expõe quando
a mídia é elaborar a é reafirma esses
estereótipos dessa mulher que tá ali bom
ela é culpada por isso a mulher tá ali
né que sofreu uma certa violência ea
mídia tá lá falando que bom ela é
culpada portanto ela assuma as
consequências né então está dupla
violação desses direitos das mulheres
também e aí para terminar né nem tudo é
só ele é nem tudo é tão difícil né a
gente tem é difícil a gente quebrar
algumas barreiras alguns estereótipos eu
acho que essa discussão de gênero a
cresceu muito nos últimos anos muito
dentro das academias também batata estão
sendo feito de muitos trabalhos que
refletem sobre a questão da mulher na
sociedade sobre a mulher negra sobre
essa mulher que pobre então trabalhando
esse gênero raça e classe então assim
pra pensar para vocês que a gente
a unidade de bom a partir de agora o
ensinam né que a minha fala seja uma
fala totalmente libertadora mas de
provocarem vocês esse pensamento de
quando se pensar em é em representar uma
mulher em representar algo você tem que
pensar essa mulher como um ser humano
como alguém que está ali com alguém que
não necessariamente tem que estar
atendendo a todos os padrões a tudo
aquilo que ela é cobrada diariamente né
então não necessariamente tem que ser
uma mulher perfeita não tem que ser a
mente né tem essas discussões já você tá
perfeito agora que tá chegando o verão o
que chove de matérias de corpo perfeito
para o verão você tem que o corpo
perfeito para o verão e aí a toda aquela
cobrança em cima da mulher um sofrimento
também cima da mulher daqui não tem
aquele corpo que não nós vezes não quer
ter também e que ali sofrendo porque a
gente tem uma sociedade que cobra e uma
mídia que elabora esses estereótipos
diariamente também né então só pra gente
pensar e refletir um pouco mais sobre
essa questão da mulher também que é
super necessário né
e tem essa violência a gente tem
mulheres sendo violentadas e
assassinadas diariamente nosso país por
serem mulher nessa é o feminicídio e é
isso gente muito obrigada